the new Westworld trailer is here and
find out why every h 'l wood was shook
reading the first script plus the latest
on the office reboot and snoop dogg is
getting in on Beyonce pike game I love
my people this is the daily Jenny and we
are back to our regularly scheduled
programming okay I'm not gonna leave
today show it Beyonce we have that for
later All Right today everybody is
talking about Westworld and listen I
know this is a good look on me but I'm
gonna keep it real with you I don't
watch it and my colleagues who do their
busy today but I couldn't ignore the
excitement surrounding season too
especially the trailer it's got you guys
all height they wanted a place hidden
from God we had something else in mind
entirely
I'm gonna burn this whole thing to the
ground
I know exactly what is out there
frighten me sometimes Dolores why on
earth would you ever be frightened of me
because you're scary you Stepford wife
all right guys have no clue what's going
on here but for fans of the sci-fi drama
here's whatever Rachel would told our
Bryce sander about her reaction to read
the script for this upcoming season we
left season one with a lot of questions
when you got that first script for
season 2 what did you think what was
your reaction I just utter disbelief I
was blown away I thought okay well let's
see how we ease back into this how you
know but they waste no time I mean we
hit the ground running in a way that I
don't think anybody saw coming okay
where do we pick up with um well I think
the showrunners have said we're not
picking up sort of exactly where we left
off but we're going to pick up in the
aftermath a bit and we're gonna see
definitely in the first episode where
Dolores is at with herself for many
souls sure I hope for all you Westworld
fans Evans reaction means something to
you cuz she's really selling it all
right guys and more TV news I got a
little something for all you fans of The
Office you guys have been campaigning
for a reboot and our Courtenay tez no
ask Andy Bernard himself about the
chance we'll see the staff at Dunder
Mifflin back on our TV screens well you
know what's something that you did very
successfully and a lot of people are
still talking about it the office they
would love for you to come back into a
reboot would you be down for something
like that I don't know what form it
would take or anything I'm sort of
agnostic I love whatever has anything to
do with that show but it's all very
hypothetical right now we'll take that
as a soft yes from Edie we caught up
with him at last night's premiere of
Chappaquiddick
and now John Krasinski told Ellen today
he's also in for a reboot
let's meet Carell not so much I kind of
don't want to do it because I I love the
show so much I just wanted to be
remembered
you know at the way people remember it
but I would have a real I want a reunion
with just the cast that'd be awesome
like at my house like a party meanwhile
one of my favorite shows is returning
soon and that is house of cards how do
we feel about Robin Wright taking over
for Kevin Spacey in the last season well
she definitely gets former co-star Kate
Mehra's boat and then can I get your
take on Rob Robin Wright taking over
Kevin Spacey's role in Highland house of
cards have you kept in touch or what do
you think about that I love Robin she
has always been one of my favorite
actresses of all time so I think she's
been sort of gearing up to take over for
a long time her character and also Robin
in real life is just such an incredible
force so I'm excited to see it
amen to that all right guys meanwhile
Tiffany Haddish made her first public
appearance since shaking the Beehive
with her mystery who bit Beyonce and it
seems everyone is hitting up for answers
but unlike Beyonce's biter her mouth is
shut and now need to stop asking me
about this be honest I said because an
da 3 I'm not saying that there now you
ain't budgin you know Tiffany hit up LL
Cool J's rollerskating party for a
Sirius XM radio station launch and
that's where e t--'s Michelle Turner
told Snoop Dogg all about queen bee's
bite pain no you have heard about the
big mystery who bent Beyonce
somebody better on the faith wow I
didn't hear about that yeah it's okay
better security Ryan Murphy is thinking
about doing American crime story who did
Beyonce Wow who do you think could play
beyond it Kerry Washington I love it I
love it you say that quick thing she's
qualified
I can see Kerry Washington you know Ryan
Murphy jokingly teased the next
installment of his American crime story
series would be who bit Beyonce so the
search is on for who will play be snoop
gave a tempting offer but I want to hear
who is your pick to play Beyonce just
have some fun with it in the comment
section I will be back tomorrow for a
new music Friday but before I go I told
you guys eat easy and reached 1 million
subscribers and these folks over at
YouTube send us this go plot I mean I
feel like Khloe Kim at the Winter
Olympics thanks to our friends over at
YouTube and thanks to all of our homies
aka our subscribers and while we have
yet once you refers to a friend thanks
for watching this is beautiful I'm gonna
hang this up on my wall
[Music]